Hello, and welcome to Clustered on the Rawkode
Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan,
although you will know me across the Internet
as Rawkode.
And we have a great episode of cluster
today with two fantastic guests.
Before we move on to that, there's just
a little bit of housekeeping. Please remember to
subscribe to the channel. The button is right
there. Click the bell and you will get
notifications for all new episodes of
the Rawkode Academy.
Also, have membership options available where you can
join for a modest fee and have access
to some of the new courses that are
being released on a weekly basis. We are
currently working through the influx DB complete guide.
We also have a Discord server available at
Rawkode.chat
where you can come and chat with 500
other cloud native and Kubernetes
enthusiasts.
Alright.
We're gonna say
thank you
to our sponsor.
Teleport has recently started sponsoring custard,
and it's been amazing to work with them.
We've used Teleport on custard since the very
first episode. It's an amazing tool. You're gonna
see it in action as we debug
these clusters.
So you want to support the Rawkode Academy,
you can go to Rawkode.liveteleport
and check it out. You'll have a lot
of fun. I promise you will love it.
Okay. Let's get started with some broken clusters
and introducing our wonderful guests today. I am
joined by Adam and William.
Welcome to Clustered.
How are you both doing?
Thank you. I'm great. And,
I'm Adam, and I'm working currently at GE
Healthcare.
But, probably, it's not too relevant anymore because
I just resigned today. So
Congratulations.
I mean Yeah. I guess.
I'm showing something else. So
Awesome. Thank you, Adam. And William?
Hi. I'm William Lightning.
I work for Field Medical Group,
an ENT practice consultancy across the
The US.
Our jobs are to be kind of the
best in the business, and
my job specifically here is to
I think to think of it as greasing
wheels.
People come to me with problems, especially programmers,
and I try and fix them, and I
try and get them past whatever is blocking
them. So
I've always told people, you know, my my
specialty is to fix things. And today,
I'm a little nervous because now I have
to prove it.
Alright.
So, I mean, I've never really asked anyone
this before, so I'm gonna put you both
on the spot for the first time ever.
But
is it fun breaking a cluster,
or is it scary? Like, what's your thoughts
on that?
Who wants to go first? Well, you're literally
gonna say something.
I it was it
was scary mostly because I'd never run before
this week.
But it was it was a lot of
fun once I got it going and and
gave me some respect for the the Kubernetes
developers
because it did a lot of healing itself
as I went.
So,
yeah, it's it's it's a lot of fun,
but it's it was nerve wrecking yesterday at,
like, 04:45, and I had to go home
at five,
and my cluster wasn't broken.
Well, that is a problem. I mean, most
people would celebrate that, but, of course, not
when you're coming out to cluster. What about
you, Adam? Scary or fun?
Yeah. Absolutely. I I had some idea how
to break it, but, unfortunately,
two of my ideas didn't work for a
very different reason on 1 dot 22 because
those are the current cluster. And, also, I
tried to, over the weekend,
prepare for this because we migrated away from,
like,
eighteen months from QADM based clusters, and we
used the the clusters based on Talos.
Those guys were here a few weeks ago.
So
I tried to install it in Oracle Cloud.
I failed, so
I'm not sure
how
it makes it justified that we switched. But
I guess
I I I didn't break it
that it cannot be fixed
for sure. And, also,
it could be done on Talos as well,
but it would be much easier to detect
because it's it's it's in
it has a lot much smaller attack surface
than a regular OS. So
Alright. Thank you. And also, we are shooting
that it can be fixed. That's always nice
to hear before we kick the episode off.
So
There there is there is two ways to
fix at least.
Alright. Well, the one is just yet. We're
gonna start our cluster in just a moment.
So I'll just say that every time I
reach out to people to come on and
enjoy us join us on clustered, people are
always really happy to come on and do
the tech sweep, but people that really
struggle to actually wanna be able to break
the clusters. And I always thought it'd the
other way around. It's nice to hear your
opinion there.
But enough with the pleasantries. It is now
time for clusters. So we are gonna start
with
Adam's cluster. William, you and I are up
first.
We've got a slightly different setup today. William
likes to keep notes as he debugs some
mushroom problems. You will see his notepad at
the top right. We have teleport available here.
I'm gonna connect to the control plane node.
William, if you could connect to that and
give me an echo hello to let me
know that you're there and we will get
started trying to fix Adam's cluster.
You can do it.
There we go. Yeah. But one of the
problems already. That's not there we go. Perfect.
Alright. So this is the Kubernetes cluster. I
would suggest that you export the cube config
and pick any command you like and see
if we have a control plane. It's usually
a pretty good first step.
You've already got your commands there ready to
go. Perfect.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Oh. Well, that's already a bad sign.
Scheduling's disabled.
But we do have a control claim. Like,
not many people are that lucky. So I'll
let's take it. That's good.
Alright. So we have
Postgres. We have the the pod there. Get
services.
Oh,
don't have my
shortcuts here.
Alright.
And we got our service. We got 3,000.
So it should be running in its current
form.
I come from a kind of a development
background, so I like to know things are
working. Would you like me to browse to
the application and check? Yeah. Would you mind?
Happy to. So we have it exposed via
Teleport secure access.
We click launch, and this should create up
a nice secure tunnel.
Our application is not working. I think Adam
has been cheeky.
Alright.
Now it's we got we got first okay.
So
let's take a look at
the cube system.
Everything's running. So we have
control plane, accordion f, Selium, API server, controller,
scheduler,
the okay. So I that's all the things
I think I'm used to seeing
as of yester
day or the day before.
Okay. So
Yeah. Things
like, even the way too easy. Are, like,
this looks way too easy. But you know
what? This is one of the most deceptive
things in cluster. Right? There's so there's so
much attack surface to break things that you
just never ever know.
Famous last words. Exactly.
So
there's no logs on the cluster. Your go
to. I'm really sorry. I'm a terrible developer.
There is no log output whatsoever on my
crappy application. Really?
Okay. Let's see. I know. I Hey. There's
there's our output. It was in
it's not my image.
Well, that might explain a lot.
Okay. So
I get pods and we'll do
Let's see. Can I tab complete? Yes. Alright.
What do we got here?
Oh, wait. Now supposedly scroll works on this.
It does.
Alright.
Are you using the web client or the
CLI?
I'm using the CLI. Nice. Okay. Cool.
Where's our image?
Image ID
clustered b.
So that doesn't seem
right to me.
Yeah. The Because
Go for it.
That's somebody else's.
Yeah. That is not the Rawkode official stamped
cluster released application.
Yeah. I'm like, that
doesn't look right.
The chat is right there with you.
But what what I have up is the
Git repo,
which does have the right image.
Yeah. It looks but, of course, our scheduler
is disabled, so I'm probably gonna break this.
Well, sometimes you gotta, you know, break it
before it gets better.
See, this is what?
Clustered.
Can I do this? Well, I would move
the size of deployment rather than the
pods. So the pod spec will be immutable,
so I don't think that will work.
Oh,
that that that's okay.
Oh, looks like somebody already applied it.
Okay.
Now this one, you'll be following me.
Mhmm. Okay. So that's
I wanna set image pull policy to always,
but I shouldn't do that. Not yet.
Oh, you're scanning for more changes.
There's a lot of stuff here that Chris,
we'll just start with that.
Yeah. I think that's a good idea.
And because we don't have a scheduler or
the scheduler is broken at least,
I don't think it'll get beyond pending.
What makes you think the scheduler's broken?
Well, in
the node,
it says scheduling disabled
for worker one and worker two there. So
I don't know if that's a scheduler broken
or if it's just tainted.
I've never I've never done anything with taint,
so this would be fun.
It's either tainted or cordoned.
Oh, good point. Yeah.
Node
worker.
I probably only need one of these.
There's well, there's a taint, cluster d app,
no schedule.
Mhmm.
So
It's also unschedulable
true, which would suggest it's potentially cordoned as
well.
Is there an idea of which
how do I remove a taint? How do
I remove a taint? That's the good question.
But this is what documentation is for. So
you can just do a cube control edit
node and then the node name to remove
the taint. Oh, sweet.
Let's see. Worker. Start with one.
That way we have second one.
Well, just a bunch of stuff here. Now
this unschedulable is not I can change that.
Right?
You can, but I'd probably run cube control
on cordon rather than modifying this back. Okay.
Yeah. So we're just gonna drop these taints
then.
Let's try that. Yeah. Go for it.
Scheduling is stable,
but that's a flag.
Okay. So kubectl
uncordon?
Mhmm.
And then just a note name.
Says,
I wish I knew Kubernetes to understand all
of this.
Well, watch a couple of them. You'll pick
it up really fast. I promise you.
Okay. That's ready,
and we're running.
So
how are we running? Are we running
alright.
If you go to the web page,
we can see something different.
You have connectivity issues. We are unable to
reach the post grads database.
Progress. We're making progress.
Okay. I'm gonna do that to the other
one,
to the other worker,
and
alright.
Let's
see. Oh, yeah. When I
okay. Let's
try that.
Oops. That's not the one I wanted.
Notes.
Let's go. I
haven't had to use my notepad much. This
is strange.
Okay.
So Postgresk,
let's see if we have any output from
post Postgresk.
I love Russell's comments. Step two of x
completed.
Because you just never know how much is
broken on this thing until you get to
the It's
true.
What do you mean pod not found? Oh,
I'm looking at services.
Wait. Was
there a service in your definition? I guess
there probably was. Okay. Yeah. The Postgres service
is there.
Get pods. That's what I'm man, I cannot
type.
Alias key. That's the greatest structure in the
world.
There we go. Like that? Yeah. And then
just key everything.
These are ones I use a lot.
And you only need to start that in
court.
This may trip me up
because
I'm so used to all my other shortcuts,
but I'm giving myself at least one.
Okay.
So we wanna do
k log
dash post grad school.
Now does ali
aliases break
tab complete, don't they?
They shouldn't.
Well, it sure didn't wanna do it. Okay.
Database was shut down. Database is ready to
accept.
That looks good.
Let's look at our definition
because this is a deployment, not a stateful
set.
Are you sure? Because
the name of the pod is dash zero,
which Oh, you're right. Just stick with it.
So we might have
pull up your thing.
Edit.
Or
k. Can I use that? No. I gotta
do STS.
STS?
Yep.
Oh, you're I'm gonna have to remember that
one.
Describe. There's not one for mutating admission controllers
or validating web controllers or configuration. Those
are dire need to I'm so glad
that we have not run into that yet
so far. Yeah.
Never too late.
Never is too late.
You know what? I'd rather describe this thing.
Let's edit it.
You're gonna edit the staple set?
Can I ask you why?
Mostly because I wanna see the YAML. I
could do git
I could do git o YAML.
Type that in the last
Are you not happy that our stateful set
is working and our pod is working?
Yeah. I mean,
kinda.
Because it's a liveliness probe.
I mean, there's something wrong with it. Of
course, I could hack into PostgresQL,
but then I'd have to install the Postgreschool
client or find the Docker container for that.
And that sounds that sounds annoying.
This should have
there's no there's no storage, though. Right?
No. So I have this configured to the
it's actually the data is bootstrapped through in
a container.
That's what I'm thinking is that the and
it's missing.
But if you think back to the error
message that we got on our browser here,
it's unable to connect and time out connecting
to the database.
Someone finally messed with IP tables?
I hope not.
There. I'm gonna put this in less so
you can see my scrolling.
Let's
see here.
Drop all anywhere.
Cube firewall.
I have a working cluster that I set
up. I'm gonna compare the output.
Is that cheating?
No. You're definitely allowed to compare it. You
you can do everyone. That's it. There's almost
no rules on cluster. Just don't break teleport.
That's pretty much it.
And you t f eight. Right?
Oh, really good. I
would suggest
maybe describing your service.
Okay. I don't think we did that yet.
Right?
No.
Because we do have endpoints,
which means the service should
be able to receive traffic on the DNS
name, on the IP address, on the port,
etcetera.
So what could block that?
K. So our selector is good.
Single stack,
54325432.
K.
I agree, Russell.
Let's
see here.
Yeah. The chat with us. No UTF,
no Unicode shenanigans, no STD shenanigans, all the
stuff that makes me cry.
See, I don't know if I can do
this from the control plane, but can I
ping these IPs?
Probably You could you should be able to
ping the pod IP. Yes.
No. That didn't work. You'll need to do
it. So you could either add a
you'd probably wanna execute inside the cluster container
to do it. Yeah. Other than setting up
your networking rules.
Throw up
Oh, no. After your e b p f
cat cat on my machine last week, that
is also banned. I'm gonna have to publish
the ban list, I think.
Is your yours is a rust application, isn't
it? It is. There there is a shell
available and the things that you should be
able to do a cube control exact dash
into the cluster pod and then you should
be able to it's Alpine so APK update
and APK install whatever you need, but ping
will be available by default.
Okay. So oh, it's it is Alpine. Okay.
Exec.
Pretty quiet there. You having fun?
Yeah. I'm I'm looking at how you try
to debug my my breaks. So
if you need any help, then I can
give some hints.
Alright. So you have a shell inside. You
should be able to run ping postgres. Oh,
no. That'll be the service. So ping the
pod IP.
Although I believe and I'm sure Noel and
Russell can help us out in the chat,
That the ability to ping a service IP
is coming and Kubernetes one twenty three or
one twenty four, which is really exciting. Oh.
Okay. Well, that ping is not returning anything.
Okay. So, yeah, you've got some sort of
policy blocking traffic to that.
Where'd you wanna look first?
I mean, Selium is the
I think that's a great idea.
Alright.
One of my former I don't if one
of one of my colleagues, former guests on
this show, gave me into trouble for leaving
Hubble on all these clusters because he said
it's it's too good a network debugging.
People still have access to it.
Let's just do this.
Path equals
path
colon
home.
Why are you putting in this Cilium NRA?
Well, that's our CNI. Right? Yeah.
And so that's I don't know. It's the
first thing I go to is what's the
tool to use for the job.
I
get rid of that. No. I don't need
but
but, of course, that's happy from there because
he
operator,
it's the versions.
Alright. We are halfway through. We got twenty
minutes left.
I'm gonna throw some suggestions out. I think
the chat said this as well, but you
should probably look for network policies on the
Kubernetes API.
Yeah. That's right.
Is that gonna be
We keep the dash e and maybe just
check on them.
Capital a starting.
Okay. So there's no basic standard Kubernetes network
policies. However, this is a silly inquisitor. So
silly has its own
types of network policies that we could check
out. I don't remember them all off the
top of my head, but you could run.
CMP and CCMP,
serial network policy sense cluster,
serial cluster network policy. Yeah. All of those.
So you could run Kube control API resources
and grep for Selium, and that'll give you
a list of all the resources available.
But Adam also just listed.
Hey,
Welcome.
Yeah. CMP and CCMP.
It's easy. CCNP.net.
Policy
And, like, network policy.
Yeah. CCNP.
Correct. Gotcha.
K.
And then there's a Cilium cluster wide network
policy.
This is the one. There is a c
c m p. That's the Selim network policy.
That's the name space code.
Yeah. Let's try and skip control API resources.
Let's just get a list of them on
and
no get.
That's right.
And that's gonna dump us a bunch of
stuff, so let's talk about Selium. Yeah.
Yeah. I'd start looking into these things. I
guess the CCNP is customer rate of our
policy. Thank you, Adam. And there's also
CMP.
CMP?
Yeah.
I was really hoping it was
a network policy, Adam, what you did here.
Mhmm. That's obviously.
Have you if you need some hints so
I can help you out.
Okay. So let's talk about the symptoms here,
William. We've got what we believe is a
working clustered pod. We have a working post
for this pod. We have a service with
endpoints.
However,
we cannot reach
the database from the application.
We've ruled out network policies, so they have
network policies, and they're still in cluster wide
network policies.
And I and we can get in
to the the the net the the other
service. Right?
Because that's how I load the web page.
So Teleport creates a proxy and uses the
node port service. So you could do a
curl local host 30,000 and you should see
the same thing.
And that delay there means we're gonna get
the time out. Yeah.
Okay.
So that's a node port. The other ones
are cluster IPs.
Correct.
Maybe? I don't know.
So why don't?
I don't know. I'm trying to think here.
What to do next? Oh my god.
Sixteen minutes left here.
Loads of time. Loads of time. Let's edit
the cluster deployment again.
Hunch right now is are we actually
that's that's it's hard coded, isn't it? I
think I hard coded DNS lookup. I don't
think it's passed in through configuration
because I'm a terrible developer.
Alright. What am I looking at? I'm going
I have no idea. Basic
check of DNS. Is the service named properly
in the deployment for clustered?
Okay. So I think what we need, we
need some more network debugging tools. I would
expect back into the cluster pod, and we
probably wanna start playing with the deck command.
Oh, okay. You want me to get back
into
Yeah. I I I think so.
Where'd you go?
There it is.
Yep.
You said Bash was available. Right? It is.
Yeah. Sweet. Okay. Let's do a if I
just maybe a Debian, we'll do an apt
update, see if it works.
Yeah. I know that. Oh, hey.
It is Debian based. Can't remember the name
of the package, so let me I'll just
quickly guess and type. But I think
I can never remember what it's actually called.
I really should, like, take note. There we
go. The initiative. That will give you the
tech command. So now you can start to
query
core DNS and see if we're getting any
responses.
Let's check
resolve.com.
Yeah. It's a good idea.
I can't see that on my local one.
Here, let me clear this. Yeah. That that
was try.
There we go. It it some of the
the teleport bits weird stuff on my end.
Okay. So that looks good.
Big postgres.
Yep.
I'm not a Qualified,
just to be sure.
Maybe need
Yeah. That's a problem. Let's
go look at our DNS. Can I I'm
gonna pop out of this? Yep.
Q.
I do appreciate you keeping everything in the
default namespace.
It makes life easier.
We won't do a dash f.
CoreDNS.
CoreDNS
is also notoriously
quiet. It doesn't particularly log too much,
but it does have a conflict map and
a keep system namespace that we probably wanna
explore.
So I would get the conflict maps in
cube system.
And there's a core DNS one there.
I see a honk.
A honk?
Yeah. I see a break.
Got it? Mhmm.
Oh, there you go. Yep.
But if we just edit this, it'll pick
it up. Right?
Might have to go off the pod. This
wonderful thing that nobody in Kubernetes land likes.
But when you modify the conflict map, you
have to rotate the pod.
Yeah.
So annoying.
Don't know why we don't have a controller
for this shit. Or we do, if someone
can share it with us.
There is one that was presented at KubeCon
a while back.
Someone had one that that embedded the hashes.
Oh, yeah. I do see that a lot
on the Yeah.
Yeah. But there's someone who actually wrote a
controller for it way back when.
Or you can just use file system notification.
It we use it in couple of our
applications,
and it's working great. So
except that it's having a couple of false
triggering when it's syncing from HCD, so you
have to ignore a couple of file system
events for
reapplying the same permissions from HCD. So
but that's a known issue for a couple
of years, so nothing
to be unexpected.
You can always judge a person based on
how to restart the pod. I am definitely
a cube control delete all kinda guy, but
I see that William You you are.
Very a very sensible approach to doing a
rollout restart. I like it.
Yeah. Because I have to remember things like
deploy slash
or DNS.
There you go. Okay.
Yep. 50% of the time,
DNS or always DNS.
Oh.
Alright.
Ten minutes, and we've got v one working.
If you refresh.
Mhmm.
Not sure why my video is playing weird,
but we do have the watch point.
Let's try and get this upgraded.
Okay.
Alright.
I I I feel like I should check
the images on the on things, but
let's just trust it and go.
So we'll get pods.
Edit.
Oh, wait.
Deploy.
Cool.
And I'm I'm guessing we just need to
edit this v two v one to v
two? Correct.
So just change that up for a two
and
apply and free.
There you go.
Alright.
And we have the dance.
How's that, William?
Nine minutes to play. Alright.
Great job about that.
Adam, did did we get everything? Was there
anything that doesn't trigger properly, or did we
did we get Yeah. It should not work.
What the
yeah. It should not work.
Can we get the cube CTR gas ports
all wide?
I love the CDL.
Don't work. Gas ports all wide. Yeah.
This is interesting.
It should not work.
Maybe I forgot something.
Alright. Well, we look forward to the breakout
notes and the repository, and we can see
what was there. But good to go, William.
I I can I can even tell it
right now? Yeah. Go for it. What would
Yeah. So, basically, I set up a harbor
instance
somewhere. Oh. And I
changed the container, the config to trusted certificate,
and changed the at c at EC host
files on the worker nodes so it would
resolve to my IP
instead of GitHub.
So I like it. That's my kinda break.
So yeah. So you you could pull the
v two image, but it was the same
image pushed.
I'm not sure why it didn't work. Maybe
I I forgot to change something.
That's sneaky. So bad. Oh, I love it.
Yeah. But I guess you you would struggle
to find that because it would actually pull
the image, and it would look fine and
everything. Did you update the container deconfig on
worker one and two to do that redirect?
I I think I did. I I I
think maybe I forgot to change in the
worker to the at t c host. I'm
not sure.
Well, never mind.
Alright. Yeah. Let's switch clusters then.
So we're gonna kill this session.
Alright. So this and I'm gonna switch over
to
one patcher. Come on. Not now.
Alright. I'll just do that over here. I
don't trust my password into my live screen
anymore. I've flashed it too many times.
I'm gonna start my victory drink.
What have you got?
It's a just a root beer. Just a
simple mug root beer.
Alright.
I have one password.
Okay.
So this is
William's cluster. Adam, you're now pairing with me
on this. I am opening a connection to
the control plane node. If you could do
me a favor, join our active session, and
then we will check for a control plane.
I guess I I see my weird screen
flash, which means I know where we're in.
Perfect.
Okay. We are in. So let me install
k nine s.
I've seen that a lot lately. I think
that's the second time we've had someone install
k nine k nine s. I'm not sure
what the pronunciation. I accidentally catch it while
it was released, like, two days after it.
And since that time, a fan. So
Nice. It's a very cool tool.
Okay.
So let's check whether if
export.
Queue config.
Let me see.
Okay. Let's check. Kube CTI version.
Okay. It's not accessible.
So, obviously, something is going on.
And I think the even the IP address
is not correct. So let's check.
Okay. I could probably check-in my cluster, but
I assume that it should be local host
anyways. So let's check.
No. I think the IP is okay. That's
the BGP advertised IP address. Ah, okay. But
that should be okay. I think we just
don't have a a running control plan.
Okay. We can check that for sure.
Seriously,
my keyboard is messing with me. So let's
check that.
Cricityl
dash r,
and let me copy
that.
So,
bots,
I think.
Qubepi server is running, but the scheduler
was
messed with. So that's something to look for
for sure. So
I think
where are the static manifests? I think in
that, you see Kubernetes.
Right? Yep.
You need a city. Yeah. Yeah.
You always forget you're not your local setup,
and you expect some of that to City
manifest
us.
And let's check what's going on with Kube
controller manager.
The image looks right.
Yep. Looks okay to me.
Yeah. That's
so why the API server is not running?
Let's look into that.
QA server.
Okay. Bind underscore.
Fishy.
At least seems so. So something is going
on why we don't have access. So
really, I've looked into EP tables, so I
guess it might has to do with that.
I think it's e IP tables.l
or something like that. So
all drop anywhere. I think that should
not be there.
Yeah. I think that should not be there.
So I think it's how you edit.
I always forget how to edit this stuff.
So
Yeah. I'm not entirely sure how to modify
IP tables with myself. Typically,
I would just flush them all.
So anything that's not processed either, we just
delete, and then you we will lose our
Kubernetes and Solium stuff. We and we pod
restart will fix that.
Yeah. Sure. We can do that.
But then I am now infamous for breaking
customers more than I am fixing them. Yeah.
I'm just trying to figure out how to
fix IP tables because I'm not that
good with it. So
I'm trying to figure out how to
You want to flush them all? Yeah. Yeah.
We can just do IP tables slash f.
Okay.
And then when you run l again, you'll
see we have a clean setup. So Okay.
Let's check again. Yeah. Let me fix our
API server or may not. I don't know.
I can see while William's sniggling.
Yeah. Let me try to
give CTL version.
It still doesn't work.
So it's still refusing.
What else it could be? Have I played
a game, Russell?
Okay. So, yeah, that didn't work.
So we took a look at the API
server manifest. Right?
Yeah.
Do mind if I just pop it open
again?
Sure.
Ah, it was cut off. Okay. That was
weird that it's so
I don't see anything that concerns me yet.
Maybe we should take a look at the
best ever logs.
Yeah. Sure. So we can check with
guess it's
less
war
logs.
Not
Kubernetes.
Container.
Container. You can just pause, but the redirect
server tracking containers is a lot easier.
No. It's no.
Warlock.
That
was the issue. Cube system, cube API
server,
and error by dialing.
Okay. So the API server cannot keep the
HCD.
Yeah.
So maybe then something is going on with
HCD.
Let's check that.
What would grow free audience? Don't fuck with
that CD. Right? I think that's what it
was.
Yeah. That's evil.
Advertise client URL.
Maybe that's
correct.
Was that running when you did the control
command? I don't I don't I don't remember.
Yeah. We can check that for sure.
Yeah. It was running.
You're very calm, Adam.
What? You're very calm.
I'm why why I would stress more than
I need to. So I I really I
really like it. I mean, I already,
little bit pissed that my my break didn't
work as intended because that would be a
fun to watch that to figure out why
you don't find the v two part. But,
anyway, it's
Next thing.
What the fuck?
Let's
check why it's
Cube system. X c d.
Okay.
Oh, it's LS.
Stupid.
Okay.
So the recommended permission, unprevised access to data.
So I guess
it has been messed with that CD. So
the permission is 755,
but the recommended permission is 7OOO.
So
Yeah.
Okay. Let's check the h c d folder,
I guess,
which should be
okay. Where h c d stores the data.
Let's check the manifest again. So less
h c d
Yellow.
And
this is where is the data?
Am I stupid, or I just don't see
where it's storing the data?
Data. Okay.
So Alice.
Okay.
This is looks fill me up.
Oh,
this doesn't look right.
So let's remove that.
This r f
Let's
see the fill me up.
Okay.
There's a great a large file there, William.
What was that? I just had to get
there.
50 gigabytes. Yeah.
It's it's pretty nice. So
maybe now we have a running control plane.
Let's check that. Permissions are still
Oh, yeah. Sorry.
So under
guess it either could be the keys or
the content, but this folder looks okay. So
let's check under what is under member. It
still looks okay.
This does not. So we can do a
CH mode
dash r,
and I
think
it should be 700.
What
is the something
is not
Then I guess it's the wrong order of
the command. Yeah. But you're I have to
change the permissions on the files.
So 700 probably be the directory and then
600, I think, for the files.
Because you wouldn't need the executable on the
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So I can change it to 500. Right?
No. 600. 6. Yeah. Six.
So
let's check if it works.
Okay. That should be fine. And then there
was another folder.
What was it? Right. Had load, but I
guess that wasn't messed with. So
okay. Let's check again the and what is
what's going on with the p k five.
So
it's it's at city p k at okay.
So as
at DC.
Kubernetes
at city.
No.
What was that?
LPKI.
That's CD.
Okay.
These certificates
having two broad access as well, so let's
change them as well.
So
ETC.
Uber.
That is speaking.
Let's see the
and
yeah. That should be fine.
Okay.
That's okay as well. So
let's check maybe now.
It self healed itself or not, we can
still
refuse.
So something is still not okay. So c
r I c t o.
That's the shop. How we can restart the
container.
Maybe stop.
Okay. So Yeah. You could just also remove
it and let the kubelet set up a
new one.
Okay.
So remove RMP.
So c r I c t l.
Okay. So the pod
name is
let's see.
Okay. So copy.
And
c r I c t l.
What was it? RMP.
Okay.
So it
it didn't remove it. Or
let's check the logs.
So
less var
log
pods.
No. I think you sent in the pod
name. I don't know if that works or
if you need the pod ID.
Oh,
yeah.
Okay. So let's try with the ID.
That looks better.
Yeah. It's gone. It has
has a new I There we go. Yeah.
It has a new ID.
So let's check the logs again. So at
CD
217.
It's running. Uh-huh.
It's no space left on device still.
So what the heck is going on? The
f is
So there's this weird thing. It's so annoying.
So
With that CD and that when an alarm
goes, you have to manually clear it. So
you're gonna need to get a CT control
installed and clear the alarm.
Okay.
But it's still full. So this is something
we are going on with this mount.
It's 200 megabyte, and it's full. Or this
is
yeah. So there's something is sneaky is going
on in this list. So I guess,
let's check again.
For.
Let's see. Maybe there is a
So these files the DB is very big.
Oh, it's six megabytes. It's okay, I guess.
Let's check the write ahead logs. The write
ahead logs are are big, so
I guess we don't really need them anymore.
So let's just
Well, they may not be compacted yet. I
wouldn't delete them just yet.
Okay. If you say so.
But there was something interesting there, and I'm
not sure, but FireLab etcd was a look
back mount.
Like, we could just unmount it, I think,
to remove the 100% usage. Like, we'd have
to stop etcd,
on mount it, and hopefully, that would expose
the
directory from the Rawkode.
And that's Okay. Making some very large assumptions
because I have no idea what William's
done.
But it should I I don't believe it
should be on the back mount in there.
Okay. We can start stop.
Yeah. It's CD.
I guess it's not restarting.
Oh, it's re no. It's not restarting.
Okay.
That's good.
Yes.
So I guess it's CU mount. Right? Yeah.
And then
war
switch
back to Hungarian keyboard again.
I'm using a US English keyboard. So Oh,
alright. That this is the this is the
command? Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
So let's check the FH again.
Okay. So nothing is full anymore.
Mhmm. So we can
we can start to
run at CT again.
So You wanna check we've got we still
got at CT database under the location?
Yeah. There was a d b file. It
was six megabytes or something like that.
But we can check again. So
what was it? And
then the number
no?
Yeah. I was worried that was gonna happen.
Yeah. So should
oh,
shit,
I guess.
So how we restore the database now?
I think we just go home and say
goodbye.
So there's gonna be a backup somewhere, and
that look back mode is gonna be on
the device somewhere. So we could go old
field and maybe run, like, a thing from
the root and look for another entity directory.
William, have the idea?
I
think I think that's a good track. I
think you'll find something at least.
Mean, most people's text stuff in temp or
slash root. So that I I would say
we look in there. People aren't very creative
when it comes to hiding stuff.
Let's
okay.
So
nothing here.
What about slash load?
Downloads.
I cannot type today.
No. Okay. That's not alright.
Not here.
I mean, mean, I know question, I had
suggested that we,
you know,
debug the loopback mode before removing it. But,
still,
we can find it.
So
Yeah.
I mean, if there's no objections, I'm just
gonna suggest that we do.
Okay.
There is one local. Yeah.
So let's
check that.
Okay. Loop back file image.
So we're gonna have to note that again
to a new location and copy the files
over.
Okay. So I need some cheat sheets for
that.
I
think we can just do
I don't know. Will this work? I I
don't I don't think I've done this before.
I'm trying it should be
mount.
There we go.
Okay.
So now we have to check that whether
we have at CD running.
Oh, well, we'll need to you.
Yeah. We have to restart it. Move member
first.
And we've now got a fresh STD started.
Okay. So we're
we're gonna have to stop the Kiplit stop
STD,
delete barlib etcd, and then restore
that member directory to the barlib etcd.
Okay.
So
yeah. Guess we
Yeah. He is absolutely
stop.
Keyblad service.
And then we have to
stop call the etcd processes or pods. Yeah.
So HCD
is running. There is two of them, actually.
So it's very good.
We have two of them. So
RMP
and then
one more.
Okay.
So now we can delete FireLab etcd.
I know.
And then or just the member director at
least and copy over.
Thanks, William. We appreciate that.
But instead of the chat, he created other
backups just in case we blew away the
lit back image.
And this was worries.
And the a directory. Yeah. So I meant
it to look back to the a directory.
Okay.
Actually, you'll need to move a member to
bar levy,
and that should
yeah. That's that should hopefully be a working
entity that we should be able to now
restart the kubelet and hope hope for the
best. We're
halfway through this, Adam. Thank thank you for
helping me out. So let's start kubelet. Maybe
we will have an actual API server now.
So I hope so.
Let's check what is running.
So at CD starting up. Let's check. Let's
be hopeful. So version.
Hey.
We have one. So we can start with
k nine s. So let's figure out what's
going on in this cluster.
Okay. So
all names. Nothing?
Okay.
This is weird.
We don't have any ports, so let's check
note
notes.
Okay. Not ready. Not ready.
That's always nice to hear.
I guess it was intentional.
So keep control get pods, all namespaces.
That's for plug in not ready. See, and
I plug in not in iOS.
Okay. So I guess he might have removed
let's let's
check on DaemonSet.
Okay. There is no,
but we also should have it in.
So is there, and it's
running
or at least seems to be.
So let's check with the control plane. So
now we have some logs.
Let's check again the notes. Maybe they are
self healing. Okay. Now we got something.
Good. Okay. So cube scheduler. I
guess something's fishy is going on it, so
I checked the config map. Maybe
I think that's fair. Okay. Let's go back
to ports
and check why it's gonna crash to back
off.
Cannot find config
to my end to okay. So I guess
it has been
messed with. So I'm
actually, don't have a cluster with me,
but it's very weird that it's expecting a
queue config.
I think it should not do that.
Yeah. We wanna go we'll probably take a
look at the static manifest. I would suspect
something Yeah. Changed.
Yeah. So let's quit and go back to
our
FTC
Kubernetes
and
where is it now? Manifest. And
then let's check.
Last
queue scheduler.
What's going on?
So it's mounting up the scheduler config. Nothing
else. And I guess it's
expecting the queue config.
So I actually should check on my
cluster because I did not break it that
what's going on.
Yeah. You can also peek into that /etc/kubernetes/scheduler.com
just to see
anything there has been tweaked or changed. Yeah.
It's it's it's it's config, so debugging it
may be a bit of a pain.
Okay. So
it cannot find this,
or this is not the right one. So
there could be
this doesn't
it looks okay. So something is going on
for sure.
Maybe just wanna check that IP address.
Yeah. We can check that. So No. No.
It's just the bank address. So maybe that's
okay.
So this is the queue config.
I
guess we can.
I mean, we don't need the working scheduler,
to be fair.
Yeah. Well, obviously, we can we can work
around that by
assigning manually.
But it would be nicer if you would
have one working.
I'm thinking what to do now.
So the scheduler doesn't work for some reason.
And that's
e t c two r to schedule. Maybe
the five permission was messed with, so we
can check that.
Wouldn't be the first one. So
this is
seems to be okay
if it's running as a root container.
Let's check that if it's running as a
root container.
So
Oh, there's an error message added clutch. So
it says cannot find the volume.
Did you see that?
Oh, I won't. The first line cannot find
volume cube config to mount out of the
container. So the static manifest must have some
sort of
volume mode mode configuration that isn't actually being
declared.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So
let's
do let's use the.
It's making more sense sometimes.
So
the mount
is
so file or create.
That's
okay, I guess.
Read only should be true.
And the volume
wait.
Volumes host pass name, queue config, and volume
month. It's
it's in the container. The name is matching
as well. So
interesting why it cannot mount the volume.
So it's it's always this.
What
the heck is going on with this?
No logs.
So only
the
so the hash is okay. The mirror port
is okay, and it should mount.
Oh, I may be and it's running on
control plane one, so that should be fine
as well.
Yeah. We've got twelve minutes. Why don't we
ignore the scheduler and focus on the work
group and then look back to the scheduler?
Yeah. Just like you said, we we can
just we can we can skip this.
So there is a hello. I guess this
is a Chrome job, so let's delete that.
We don't care about this. Sorry,
William.
Jobs. Okay.
That's okay.
Now it's cleared up. So let's check.
Not ready. Not ready. So it's not scheduled,
it's completed. So completed is not the port
status.
So I guess there should be a job
or something like that.
A pod can complete if the process exits
with a zero.
Okay. Let's check the the money first.
So
so
this is v one for sure coming from.
Okay. Let's check deployment.
I cannot type.
Okay. So describe.
No volume.
Now let's check the replica sets.
There is only a single replica set. So
it has been either cleaned up or something
else is going on.
And based on the age, something else should
be going on. Why it's not ready?
So the other nodes were fine.
Yeah. They're And
the serial port started fine.
So that should be okay.
Okay.
What the I'm not sure what's we can
why it's quitting? So do we have no
replica sets at all?
No. We have we have our replica sets.
So Okay.
So let's try just updating the image to
v two.
Sure. We can try that.
You don't feel like that. You don't feel
confident that's gonna work.
Yeah. I'm I'm mildly hopeful.
We won't.
Okay.
So let's check
Cluster pending because we don't have. So
should we directly edit the pods? Yeah. That's
it.
So where is it?
You could just add node name to the
spec.
Yeah.
Here. Right? Yep.
It's like the the last case and h.
I
cannot edit this. Yeah. We'll need to oh,
yeah. Oh, no. We should be able to
change the
I must have the field name. Oh, no.
Not not name is there.
Yeah. It's
cannot be changed.
That's what I hate about bots. Let's just
add it to the deployment
on the template spec.
Sure.
So deploy.
We're not fetching your scheduler, William. There you
go.
So let's find where is the port. So
it's here. So port's back.
That's under container. So port's back. This is
here.
I hate that them does that. So I
Ah,
always forget.
Okay.
Let's see what's happening with the bot. Here
we go. Okay. Container creating.
I could check the logs, but it's not
my NGINX container that always give back an
internal server error. So
Hopefully, it's just pulling
an image. There we go.
Okay.
So
we have okay. So we have to fix
the stateful set as well.
So
let's put it on the same note.
It should be fine.
So
I think we may have to delete that
part because it says it's a stateful set.
Yes. It's one to roll out automatically. Sure.
I'm curious how you got the completed state
on that volume. You need to you need
to share that with this one. We're done.
That that is better now. Shall I try
and merge the application?
Yeah. We can, I guess, we can check
it? Maybe it will work. Maybe it's not.
Oh, we got that.
Oh. So
I could not fix the scheduler,
but at least we got there
with some
with some almost dead cluster.
Yeah. That was I was
it was interesting.
Like, I must add are there any breaks
there that we we navigate around their volume,
or was the entity the big one?
The the XCD was the big one. Yeah.
I I figured that would be it, and
I just did a one line change on
the cube scheduler. I'm pretty sure you guys
broke it while messing with XCD, though.
Yeah.
Unfortunately,
I had a one one more idea to
to mess with your
cluster, but it did not work either because
of one dot 22.
So
I I I had some more ideas, but
I ran out of time, and that was
probably for the best given
given how long that took. This was really
great.
Yeah. May may maybe a heads up for
future. Cilium currently doesn't support, but there is
a nice service
property in one dot 22 that you can
create a service with
local,
internal traffic policy.
And if you that's why there was a
change there because I tried to do that,
but fig I figured out that CDM still
doesn't support.
And because David installed the cluster without Qproxy,
it didn't work because supposedly with Qproxy, if
I would restore that, it would respect the
the rules. So
Damn me. And my Qproxy free clusters. Sorry.
I don't Yeah. That that was a that
was a sad thing to to happen.
Alright. Well, tell me, how did you get
the completed status on the cluster of postcards
pods?
I have no idea.
That is not something I broke.
And people say Kubernetes is hard. The the
the etcd and and compressing that into
a small volume and then trying to get
it to fill the disk, that was really
hard. Etcd really didn't want to die.
And then I just I just configured the
scheduler to write its config out and die.
There's one command line option in there that
just so that's why it was dying. So
all the volume stuff, I think, was when
you guys were messing with the permissions because
I didn't mess with the permissions anywhere.
STD license is great. I guess that's what
happened there.
Alright. Well, thank you both,
Adam and William. Those were two great clusters,
and you both did really well working through
that. In fact, I I had a pretty
much hands off experience. You both absolutely smashed
that. So great job.
Was fun.
Thank you, William.
It was a lot of fun. Joining me.
Thank you to Teleport, our sponsor. Remember to
go check out Rawkode.live/Teleport.
You've seen us using it today as an
awesome product. I encourage you all to install
it in your clusters. And thank you to
everyone who's watching and your comments along the
way. We'll be back next week with a
couple of members from the Discord community. We
have Carlos and Eric. It's gonna be another
amazing episode. So once again, thank you, Adam.
Thank you, William. Have a great day. Bye.
Thank you. You too.